je crois que cette publicité je ne crois
pas je suis convaincu cette publicité
doit être retiré c'est pas une question
de liberté de parole les dix on peut
dire des conneries des bêtises avec la
liberté de parole et c'est pour ça que
la liberté de parole existent pour qu'on
puisse critiquer les gens qui écrivent
ces choses nous qui disent ces choses
sur leurs opinions
maintenant est ce que les pouvoirs
publics à ce que les fonds publics
doivent être engagées pour soutenir la
diffusion de ses opinions
ça c'est une autre une autre enjeu je
crois pas qu'il soit approprié quand on
engage des fonds pour soutenir même si
on savait probablement ces détails on
sait le problème en pas au moment où
l'annoncé a été acheté ou placé
maintenant qu'on sait que c'est le genre
de message qui est véhiculé il y existe
la liberté d'expression les gens encore
une fois peuvent dire le même les pires
choses sauf les appelle la violence et à
la haine on le sait dans notre
législation
mais on n'a pas nécessairement à
soutenir sa est certainement pas
soutenir ce avec des fonds publics